- [Instructor] So we
have two vectors here,
vector A and vector B.
And what we're gonna do in this video
is think about what it
means to add vectors.
So for example, how could we think
about what does it mean to take vector A
and add to that vector B.
And as we'll see, we'll
get another third vector.
And there's two ways that we
can think about this visually.
One way is to say, all right,
if we want start with vector
A and then add vector B to it,
what we can do, let me
take a copy of vector B
and put its tail right
at the head of vector A.
Notice I have not changed the magnitude
or the direction of vector B.
If I did, I would actually
be changing the vector.
And when I do it like that,
this defines a third vector
which can be use the sum of a plus B.
And the sum is going to
start at the tail of vector A
and end at the head of vector B here.
So let me draw that.
So it would look something like that.
And we can call this
right over here, vector C.
So we could say A plus
B is equal to vector C.
Now we could have also thought about it
the other way around.
We could have said,
let's start with vector B
and then add vector A to that.
So I'll start with the tail of vector B
and then at the head of vector
B, I'm going to put the tail
of vector A.
So it could look something like that.
And then once again, the sum
is going to have its tail
at our starting point here
and its head at our finishing point.
Now, another way of thinking about it is
we've just constructed a parallelogram
with these two vectors by putting both
of their tails together,
and then by taking a copy
of each of them and
putting that copy's tail
at the head of the other vector,
you construct a parallelogram like this,
and then the sum is
going to be the diagonal
of the parallelogram.
But hopefully you appreciate
this is the same exact idea.
If you just add by
putting the head to tail
of the two vectors and
you construct a triangle,
the parallelogram just helps us appreciate
that you can start with the yellow vector
and then the blue vector
or the blue vector first
and then the yellow vector.
But either way, the sum is
going to be this vector C.